My street treatment recommendations stipulated no dairy would this restrict me from using organic
ghee. So typically, if you're going to use organic ghee, you're going to use it to spread
on toast or something like that. So we have said, and it's in your binder, that yeah, you
could use some ghee. Don't worry about that. Even if you're on no dairy, we've had people ask,
well, can I put a little bit of cream? I only use a tablespoon in my coffee every day. Is that
okay? Remember, this is a diet. This is a recommendation. This isn't a cult. So of course, you could
do that. You know, it's just, hey, I'm not going to be eating cheese. I'm not going to be eating,
you know, I'm restricting the greater part of dairy consumption that I've had. Well, I could drop my
dairy consumption by 90%. You're going to have a huge impact on growth factors. So don't make
this a obsessive, compulsive, cult-ish lifestyle. You know, you do the best you can. Certainly,
use it or get a key. I just have no trouble with that.